the corvid 19 outbreak in the city of
shanghai the financial capital has now
reported more than 22 000 new cases
residents are losing patience after
being cooped up at home for more than a
month the echoes of people crying out
from their windows for help
this woman's door was kicked in by
police when she refused to go to
quarantine robots patrol some streets
reminding people to wear
in getting masks
and poor conditions at central
quarantine facilities and people being
forced out of their homes as the city
enters its third week of covid lockdown
so you're xi jinping the head of china
you've been putting your peasants
through the most brutal coveted
lockdowns in the world
your subjects are being forced to stay
in their homes even when their food and
medications are running out children who
test positive get separated from their
parents without so much as a goodbye
even the cities that are on lockdown
spend every single day in fear that
they'll be next on the list and it's all
thanks to your zero coveted policy your
promise to do whatever it takes to get
china's covert cases down to zero no
matter the cost
but your grand plan has had an
unintended consequence your rich people
want out
you see in your lockdowns it doesn't
matter if you're a peasant or a rich
businessman living in a pet house
they're all trapped in their homes just
the same no rich people privilege and
the businesses that made these
businessmen rich well most of them are
probably going under as well since no
one can step outside and buy stuff it's
gotten so bad that 10 000 wealthy
chinese men and women worth over 48
billion dollars plan on leaving china as
soon as possible and that is a problem
you see if you're going to get china to
overtake the us as the world superpower
you need money you need the chinese
economy at full steam and as with any
economy the chinese economy is powered
by the rich business owners if they
leave and take their money with them
people won't have jobs the economy will
crumble
so even though this is all your fault
for punishing the few subjects that
actually keep your economy running it is
your duty to protect the interests of
the public at all costs by never letting
the rich leave
these rich people are only rich because
you allow them to be anyways so if they
try to leave you gotta make them suffer
my name is jake tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player
your parents teachers friends society
will never teach you any of this so
we're going to
stay dangerous and this is the great
chinese exodus
[Music]
although the government doesn't want to
admit it we are definitely in a
recession already and guess what the
average recession lasts 17 months which
means the next one or two years is not
looking very bright unless you prepare
right now remember you want to be greedy
when there's blood in the streets and if
this recession is anything like the 2008
recession where home prices fell as much
as 40 to 50 in some areas or even over
60 in places like las vegas you're gonna
want to learn how to swoop up all this
real estate at fire sale prices and that
is where me kevin's real estate
investing course comes in me kevin is
one of the biggest investing youtubers
out there and in this course he teaches
you how to go from zero dollars in net
worth to millionaire and beyond using
real estates i actually bought this
course with my own money and went
through it a few years back and it is
amazing i had zero real estate knowledge
and i bought a lot of online courses in
my day so i can tell you with confidence
that this is the most comprehensive real
estate investing course out there and i
even ended up buying my parents a house
using the knowledge i learned in this
course meet kevin teaches you how to buy
real estate that's under market value do
easy cosmetic upgrades to it to increase
its value so your property becomes worth
way more than what you put in this is
what he calls finding wedge deals and
it's actually pretty simple and he goes
over every possible little thing you
could need to know with over 400 video
lessons but my favorite part of this
course is that me kevin does live
streams where you can show him deals
you're looking at and he'll analyze them
on the spots i've done this before with
him on a live stream and it's really
cool so if this sounds at all
interesting to you pause the video and
go to jake.yt real estate by clicking
the link below take a look at what's
inside the course for yourself in a row
right now before the price increases
that's jake.yt real estate with the link
below to enroll now
even before kovid brought chaos to china
it wasn't exactly at the top of most
people's dream countries to live in list
pollution poor safety standards mass
surveillance corruption and almost zero
freedom of speech and expression none of
these really appeal to educated wealthy
people looking to make better lives for
themselves and their families so it's
not really surprising that even back in
2013 a lot of rich chinese citizens were
looking for a way out
instead of being stuck in a country
where your money could be taken from you
where you could be thrown in jail if the
government was having a bad day these
rich chinese citizens wanted to move to
places like america canada europe and
australia
places where they would be free to say
and do what they want where they would
have access to better education more
freedom cleaner air and healthier food
disgusting stuff like that
so to discourage your subjects from
leaving you you instituted a new rule
that only allowed your subjects to take
fifty thousand dollars out of the
country every year
fifty thousand dollars when you're
moving to a new country with your entire
family that's harsh
just the way you wanted it
but these meddling peasants eventually
found a lot of ways around this law like
buying crypto or moving their money
through macau the las vegas of asia
where casinos allow customers to buy
gambling chips in yuan and then exchange
those chips for foreign currencies like
euros or dollars
and if your subjects needed to move very
large amounts of money out of the
country they could also arrange an
exchange with a foreign business looking
to invest or work in china they would
give them one million dollars worth of
yuan in china moved to the country they
wanted like the trader they were and in
that new country they would be handed
one million dollars in whatever currency
they wanted
all of these loopholes made it possible
for chinese citizens to move to the west
if they really wanted to but then kovit
hit and it was time to crack the whip
[Music]
right off the bat you held no mercy to
stop the spread of covid people were
left stuck in their apartments without
food tesla workers were forced to sleep
in the company's factories bankers were
trapped inside their offices and over 33
000 people were locked up in disneyland
to undergo testing before they could
leave
people were living in constant fear of
testing positive or coming into contact
with someone who had covid which would
then lead them to getting shipped off to
some strange quarantine camp far away
from their families and their homes
and all of these measures meant not only
were your subjects suffering mentally
and developing anxiety and depression
but the chinese economy was slowed down
to a halt
today over 18 percent of china's youth
are unemployed and the economy is
growing at a snail's pace slower than
ever before compared to recent years
and that wasn't even the worst of it
because just as the world started
opening up that's when you announced
china's zero covid policy could last
another five years
five more years of keeping your subjects
docile and contained yes please
since the start of the zero covid
program migration consultants and
lawyers said the number of people asking
how to leave china has tripled and in
some cases it multiplied by five and
searches for terms like how to move to
canada increased by more than three
thousand percent
right now around ten thousand wealthy
chinese citizens and three thousand hong
kong residents are planning on leaving
just this year
and they're planning on taking their
over 60 billion dollars of collective
wealth with them
if that happens this exodus of rich and
educated people will be the second
largest for any country in the world
second only to russia thanks to their
recent invasion and sanctions
the only question is how will we prevent
them from leaving this time
only around 10 of chinese citizens have
valid passports and applying for visas
and moving to a new country without a
passport is near impossible
and that's where we get our first
solution to keep our subjects from
leaving you see thanks to kovid we've
been able to use that as an excuse to
implement strict travel restrictions
that block chinese citizens from
traveling out of china for anything the
government thinks is non-essential this
has made it very difficult for people to
get passports so they can apply for
visas to move
which then brings us to our next step
even if chinese citizens could get the
passports visas and the permission they
needed to actually leave the country we
gotta shut down all the loopholes
they've found over the years to get
their money out of the country that's
why in 2021 the chinese government
banned crypto trading meaning no one
could use bitcoin or ethereum as a way
to move their money out of china anymore
that's why we've also cracked down on
macau's casinos that used to let chinese
citizens exchange their yuan for foreign
currencies and since not many foreigners
are looking to start business or invest
in china right now that other route
where chinese citizens would give
foreigners yuan in china and then get
paid back in a foreign currency once
they moved out is also now basically
shut down
but as always these pesky subjects of
yours are still finding new creative
ways to get around all these crackdowns
but rest assured this is like a game of
whack-a-mole as they find new loopholes
to get their money out you just gotta
crack down hard on them to remind them
who's boss
china has done some pretty shady stuff
in the name of patriotism and the
greater good but none of that could
compare to the lengths america is
willing to go to achieve its goals and
maintain its status as the moral compass
of the world
just take the war on terror as an
example for nearly 10 years cia
operatives and american soldiers would
kidnap and imprison hundreds of their
arabic enemies and subject them to some
of the most violent ruthless
enhanced interrogation techniques the
world has ever seen they would keep
these suspects in secret prisons all
around the world never telling them why
they were being held or when they would
have a chance for a fair trial and it
didn't matter that a lot of the cia's
suspects actually turned out to be
innocent in their mind all of these
enhanced interrogations were for the
greater good this practice of kidnapping
and questioning prisoners in secret
prisons became known as the cia's black
site program and the stuff they did to
their prisoners is honestly the darkest
most evil topic we've ever covered on
this channel
but obviously going into all the deep
dark bloody depths of the cia's black
site program would definitely get
demonetized by youtube
that's why we've released it as a
private full-length documentary that's
only available to members of this
channel all you have to do to get access
to this documentary and lots of others
on topics like efforty jepstein the bin
laden papers and mkultra the cia's mind
control program is to hit that join
button below once you do you'll have
exclusive access to this insider
information on how the world works that
no one will ever teach you in school or
university every single month
and unlike university we're not gonna
charge you thousands of dollars to learn
these things
becoming a member only costs five
dollars a month and trust us these
videos are way more entertaining than a
lecture could ever be plus there's a
refund policy unlike most youtube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund
[Music]
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you're new here this is one of the
biggest channels on youtube for doc and
memories on money power war and crime we
make multiple videos just like this one
every single week for free so click that
subscribe button below but that's going
to wrap it up stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
you